[Music]
okay everybody I am so so excited today
because I am joined by Natasha tosini
AKA Lara and Winnie the Pooh Blood and
Honey which is in theaters now how you
doing today Natasha
um okay thank you how are you I'm doing
really good I'm so excited to talk about
your part in this film and the film in
general this is literally the film
everybody is talking about what blew me
away just about the reception of the
trailer got is also that when IMDb
released its most anticipated films of
the Year this was number two so did you
have any clue like when you even on set
or anything like did you have any just
inkling that this was going to get this
kind of reception
um to be honest no
I didn't to be fair when I read the
script I was like
what the hell
um obviously it's Winnie the pose so
because he's so memorable anyway and
everyone knows him it's like I knew
there'd be a lot of people that were
like what the hell and it would get some
notes in but nowhere near as much like
publicity it's got yeah 100 and just in
general with anything you've done
because you've also modeled you've acted
before you've written is there anything
like in general just with the like
experience you've had just being
involved with this film that made this
one feel special or different just to
the reception of people have been giving
it
um
obviously this is the best one I've had
like this is obviously the biggest one
I've done this but to be honest I don't
think anything felt different because it
was the first feature I did hmm so I'd
done like short movies and like I did a
documentary I did like obviously
modeling and stuff but in terms of
features this was my first one
so this one kind of like based the rest
of my experiences if you know what I
mean because it was my first time
yeah no that that's really cool and
that's exciting than being your first
feature film that it's something this
exciting and like thrilling to be a part
of that's that's crazy uh so did all
this attention it's already been brought
to the film before it's even come out
does that bring extra anxiety to you and
how the film's gonna be received when
people actually see it
um it did to me personally
um there was a few reasons why so the
first one was I was like
when I when I realized everyone was
going to watch it I was like oh my God
because I hate watching myself like even
in just a music video I'll come on and
go God why did I do that oh my God look
at me oh my god I've got forehead
creases and stuff like because you do
like super analyze yourself don't you
and I feel like
sorry about that that's the dog's
barking back there
um I feel like I was always super
analyzing myself so when I realized
everyone all my friends all my family
everyone I knew people I didn't know
everyone was going to watch it I was
like oh no everyone's gonna watch me but
then I think it kind of died down a
little bit and now I'm just I'm super
excited for everyone to see it now yeah
for sure and I could totally get like
you feeling that feeling but I mean
people are going to love you in this and
it's interesting too how did this
part for Laura come about for you did
you have to audition for different
characters was there a lot of auditions
for this just the whole process of this
so at the point that I got the role
obviously like I said it's my first
feature and I didn't even have a show
real I didn't have a show real I didn't
have any experience in features
um I think I was like
an extra in one feature before I did
Lara
um and I seen it and I was like oh my
God like I had I when I saw it had the
same reaction that the rest of the world
has had now I was like oh my God like I
really want to be a part of this
um I sent like um a message saying like
I want to be a part of it and stuff and
they asked me for a self tape and I was
like okay sure and I'm pretty sure it
was like my first ever self tape and I
was so nervous
um I set myself to it and within about
half an hour they were like yep
wow okay
yeah that's amazing and uh okay when you
when you read into that part of Laura
did you find a lot of yourself in that
character for sure 100 I feel like
Laura's a little bit more ditzy than me
like she's she's a little bit like
the character that you see and like saw
or scream and she'll be running and she
trips and you're like
she's a bit that character but I do see
myself in her like
she's very comedic she's sassy and I
feel like that's me so it worked really
really well for me because I kind of
just played myself it was very
naturalistic because I was just playing
myself
yeah no that's a great answer and uh
yeah that's always I feel like an
awesome way to just like do a roll too
naturalistically so that's insane here
and is it true too that the film was
originally just shot over 10 days like
was this a quick shoot and was there
more reshoots as well it was a quick
shoe I don't know exactly how long it
was but it was a quick shoe and there
has been a lot of reshoots for sure I
was involved in
I think I was only involved in one
reissue but I know there were a lot more
reshoots for like different characters
and different people and stuff
yeah for sure no and um it's interesting
too that's really cool that like it was
a quick shoot as well and it ended to
film that again is getting all this
attention it's such a great story in
general and I mean was being on set for
you with the killer poo and piglet was
that like hard to take seriously at
first or did you kind of settle in right
away with that
well it's kind of it's kind of strange
because the actor who plays
um Winnie the Pooh Craig I met him
before he had his suit on so I was like
hi nice to meet you and we had a chat
and staff and then he was like oh I
played I was like oh so that kind of
like took the like strangeness a little
bit away because I knew who he was in
real life
but it was like oh God when I met um the
guy who plays piglets his name's Chris
it's so sweet but I didn't meet him
before I seen him with the suit
right so I'd like seen him but not
spoken to him or like spend any time
with him the first time I'd actually
like
paid attempt like paid attention enough
to like have a conversation with him was
when he had the mask on and that was on
scene on set like in a scene and I was
absolutely petrified I'm such a wimp
when it comes to like horror movies
anyway like I I don't watch them because
I'm so scared
like I recently
um went to the premier the Mexico
premiere for Winnie the Pooh and the
whole time I was watching it I was
holding my friend's hand going I'm
scared I'm scared I'm scared like even
though I'm in it I was super scared so
seeing him in real life with the piglet
mask on especially because he's like
oh it's horrible and creepy it's so
horrible and creepy but it was very very
scary in real life that's good I feel
like I guess that would help the
performance too right that you're
actually yeah exactly I wasn't expecting
I was just petrified I love that and uh
also it's cool because like we mentioned
earlier interview that you have written
before you have modeled but all this
attention now it's putting on this
acting career now being in your first
feature film does that make you want to
focus more on acting Now is acting your
number one love
definitely actin's my favorite thing to
do
um I did modeling for a while and I did
FHM I'm seeing you saw on my Instagram
um and that's super fun doing stuff like
that but you can't you don't really meet
many people and all I've wanted to do is
like make friends and meet people
because I'm really sociable and stuff
doing modeling it's like get changed get
changed pose pose pose get changed get
Chinese pose whereas there's not really
really many people there but with acting
and obviously I do I don't know if you
know this but I do only funds as well
and obviously doing that I'm doing that
from home I have I like I don't I just
do that alone it's just completely just
may so I don't meet anyone I don't make
any friends it's quite a lonely business
to be a person like modeling and stuff
so that's actually originally why I
wanted to do acting because I'd had like
a um split with my ex-boyfriend and I
don't really have any many friends left
you know when you're in a relationship
that's not really
I won't say bad things but it's not a
positive relationship and you kind of
got everyone off and everyone tells you
from the start this is bad news and
you're like well I'll give it a try and
then everyone gets sick of it and you've
kind of got no one left at the end it
was a bit like that so that's actually
why I started doing acting because I was
like I want to meet people only fans I
can't meet anyone modeling couldn't meet
anyone
um
so yeah my main goal in acting was to
make friends and I've made so many
friends I feel like acting is definitely
what I'll do for the rest of my life for
sure oh that's a great answer and that's
like a great Point too about Community
with acting and yeah it turns out well
too because it's like feels like things
are getting back to normal people are
out and doing projects together so
that's great and um
it's interesting too so with this film
and then the community of the film also
on the top of community just like I'm
excited to watch this in theaters with a
big crowd so what as being a part of the
project what do you want
the crowd to be feeling when they come
out of this like what do you want this
movie to do then if that makes sense
um
oh that's a really good question I've
not had before
I guess
well because it's a horror I want them
to be a little bit scared because I had
to be scared so I want everyone to be a
little tiny bit scared
um
personally for me and just me and myself
if they came out of it and they enjoyed
my character that I played and they
thought I played the character well and
they liked me as a person then I'd be
super pleased with that for sure oh and
that's definitely gonna happen so that
that's really cool and I like that
answer and
do you think now even besides your
character the other thing is having
these two iconic poo and piglet
um in these new roles do you think
people ever be look at them the same
after seeing this film like for people
on the fence like I love poo and piglet
my childhood friends like are you are
they gonna be able to do that again or
is this going to kind of ruin that
um I don't know I think when people
watch it they'll go right they are so
diff for me when I watch
like other Winnie the Pooh films I I
love Winnie's poem both types but like
the first one
I love all of them films and when I
watched them at first I'm like Winnie
the Pooh but then I'm like I'm over it
because they're so different and
everything about them so different that
it's like
I don't know my brain doesn't like you
know when you watch a movie with a
character you really like and then you
watch that same character in something
else and you're like oh and I liked him
in that and this is a I like him in this
as well because I like him it's
completely like I normally struggle with
that because I can't get into the
character then because I know it is
something was winning the poem I think
because they look so different and they
act so different and there's so many
differences your brain doesn't really
make the connection I've got a daughter
she's she's turning three in Feb and she
know like she's seen the trailer
um
we look today and because obviously I
wasn't I didn't think she'd realize what
it was so obviously because I'm in it I
was like look at this and then she was
like
but anyway she wasn't scared which is
great
um she knows the difference and she'll
say like I want to watch bad Winnie Pooh
she'll say when he does this to you
because I've seen the trailer of my
mouth or if she wants to watch good when
he posts she'll say me want to watch
Good Winnie Pooh and she kind of like
she knows the difference but I don't
think she even realizes it's meant
Winnie the Pooh I think she thinks
they're completely two different things
like Winnie the Pooh and Winnie the Pooh
you know what I mean yeah I do uh and
that's cool they brought that example
with your daughter in it and yeah yeah
that's like I think what's so
interesting about the song Too is like I
feel like there could be studies on the
just how this whole film like the effect
it has on people but also like how it
came about everything it's really
fascinating and
um do you have a specific character from
Winnie the Pooh that's are you a poo gal
or do you like piglet any of favorites
Eeyore
oh
and piglet
um
I'd say I love them both the same okay
good I love that so everybody watch
Natasha crush it in Winnie the Pooh
Blood and Honey which is in theaters now
and make sure to follow her on Twitter
and Instagram at Natasha tocini and on
Tic Tac tick tock not Tic Tac real
Natasha tosini thank you so much for
joining me today Natasha I hope to talk
to you in the future one day thank you
so much have a May